this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu
Oh
good morning she gave it up beginning
dusty on home I was electric sector
let's give up I know I've been here for
two days and I had a privilege of of
performing with another part of honor
and acting ensemble yesterday morning so
that meant to Josh to declare for me
even harder day then I came up here
that's another story I like to be able
to sing good morning to everyone I'm
very excited to be here this morning to
be able to share the story of a national
comprehensive sunflowers and those
individuals that we serve all in-ground
every day the gentleman adopt a fully
love talk about I see them from every
day a week I deal with their pain I see
the anguish and we work very very hard
since 1999 but to provide when we create
solutions that can make sense so that
end of the day the statement that you
had on the handout the number whenever
was passed out if not hope that they
will start passing them out there would
be a good thing because on a handout I
said that national communist assemble
father's is leading the fight to it our
fathers and unite families that's what
we do our program just give you a brief
mystery really started in nineteen
ninety nine it is funded through the
Department of welfare your deployment
training and the program that started
with the thought so I woke up one day
and they say well if you help the
father's maybe the Father's will help
thee
families from our welfare rolls what a
thought and the food of the Workforce
Development Corporation in Philadelphia
open their father initiative program I
took over the program as a program
manager in 2001 when I took over the
program was pretty much treated like a
stepchild denby dance Logan father's
these guys could not be reached all
those things were said and they served a
hundred minute at that time they had
four provides thrust city of
Philadelphia tercera probably 25 min
each and they couldn't make the air
moment knows when I took over the
program in 2001 we were so successful in
the first year then the state-mandated
us to be a demonstration project and
what that meant was for you those who
know about funding I've got more money
and I got a chance to think outside the
box we develop for our program a
fraternity concept which was called
Delta Alpha Delta dance Doug our Delta
Sigma dance which still stands today
that fraternity concept gave the men in
our program a sense of belonging and
gratification it made them feel as
though they were involved is something
that was greater than themselves and
today it stands true we know my
fraternity's our mentor in our community
as a resource for Brotherhood for
respect for love for being able to think
about something that's greater than
yourselves and that works for the men in
our program it worked for the providers
at that time we stayed at the
Philadelphia Workforce Development
Corporation for three more successful
years and i went to the powers that be i
asked them could i develop this program
as a standalone project because i saw
that we needed to really to provide
stronger direct services to those men
that we preserve and they granted us to
do that they asked us this suggested
that we come under the Greater
Philadelphia
first coalition which is a organization
in Philadelphia that was existed for the
past 35 years to help nonprofit and
human service organizations in the
community better provide the human
services that are needed for our
community it came out of the revolution
of the 60s when the grassroots
organizations marek corporate america
because corporate america was saying to
those grassroots organizations in
Philadelphia we don't know what to do
get help us and there's got the full of
said this morning that same question
still exist and they're asking the same
thing we don't know what to do can you
help us so as a national competition
some of our fathers we're try to feel
that question I'm trying to feel that
questions and make some realities happen
so that's my story we stayed at the
relevant Workforce Development
Corporation for three more successful
years and moving to the greater fill of
Urban Affairs audition I knew that we
needed to expand direct service programs
that we had so what do we have we had
our fatherhood initiative program delta
delta sigma before we left the hood of
the workforce development corporation we
opened the first work in style wardrobe
in the tri-state area philadelphia where
we dressed men that are going to court
we're going to look for jobs and even
the homeless today we dress over a
thousand and a year when they go to
court me look better but they look for
the job but maybe really want one and
the end and you should see some of those
young men when they come in and gotten
pants all we got rounded behind they put
that suit on and then step in a menacing
is that me and I say yesterday also good
at it
they'll destroy it no the we also knew
that we needed to expand by moving to
the benefit of urban affairs coalition
we develop a legal service for
Responsible father's we open a mentoring
program three the three air project man
measuring man because the whole notion
of that we could pull ourselves up by
our bootstraps in forge ahead and don't
need any help of that section we cry we
suffer we we have the same girls as
everyone else and I thought we suffer
from the job man syndrome that we think
we can write on the whiteboard to save
the day well I tell have been enough
program John name is Dan and it has to
be a new sheriff in town and so here's
our story when we develop the National
copy of several fathers we go through a
tremendous growth period a tremendous
blessing that we could have these
extended programs that really made a
difference in those people that we were
serving we saw immediate change in those
demographics they will say those
disregarded and set to the side why
because of thematic that we put inside
of organization from the recession's to
the executive director just says that we
have the gear these men love ever set
for the door love and respect and give
them a genuine feeling that they belong
so our fraternity concept really works
in reference to them feeling that they
are a part of something that they
control the day though vested interested
anyway okay now could tell my story
about for the rest of the afternoon
since uh dr. Wallace gave me four hours
at all but I'm going to shorten uh I'm
going shorten that and what I like to be
able to do it this time is to be able to
show you a short video that was throwing
our program so that he can speak for
itself
for the first time in u.s. history one
in 100 adults now live behind bars that
according to a few Center very startling
numbers and particularly the
incarceration rate of african-american
men or receipts any other racial group
effective as to the dysfunctional
families nationwide but there are people
in programs out here trying to help them
become stand up father's responsible
fathers we're sort of texture they need
this stage play is called fully up it
was created by the Toba theater company
and design of the draw attention to the
effect that incur serrated men have on
society as a whole and on their families
it was reformed in center city by former
prisoners and women with loved ones in
prisons the prefers was probably
national conference on fatherhood that
was helpful of a percent of men that are
in jail that are interested regardless
of color net had a father energy that
night seventy percent of the families
across America or about single would if
I have to talk to them but the question
is where thought us and this is
something that we can we can make a
difference until you've heard from
speakers from all walks of life we
meeting immediate problems from all
across the country and you find out that
is uniqueness and anybody suffering from
the same problems which are going
through Alaska or regrow a virgin
islands or the UK
the same common theme of the family he
fragmented in for service intervention
the three-day conference was a chance
for attendees to here and share ideas on
various ultimate issues and initiatives
initiatives and programs that can make a
difference permit in need some men and
need a change their difficult
circumstances go to the comprehensive
center for in center city for
nothing I was shot five times most
aggressive guy God will out here talking
to you right now for a bonus out there
see that you can change I was getting a
bit about basically I'd knives and made
some bad choices some bad citizens and a
lateral type of people and you know
businesses data control on that they
actually just kind of started out of
control and a appreciative with a
committee fountain of wisdom so
basically its kind of had to go along
without being somewhere so I our senior
spreadsheet charged enough from both
days seven years at the literal
comprehensive sooner for fathers it's
cheerfully we don't refill like internet
service and computers and your developer
Brotherhood while learning how to learn
French relationships with your children
and families at issue bauza family and
work that has held in balanced assume
they think the difference by providing
additional educational workshops and job
placement because so do not assume your
father's age 18 and over there's also a
clothes closet for men who complete the
program Kofi of Sunday's executive
director he gets frequent calls about
his program and it's it's more than just
a father initiative program it's more
than just japnis that place is about
looking at the whole person and
really putting all our energies and all
of our efforts forward to be able to
change that person around it's like a
spiritual rebirth that leads to
character this program is starting this
program other than Philadelphia
Workforce Development Corporation in
1999 and it was mandated at that
particular time that there any wealth
had a work system that they start to be
able to deal with fathers and men I job
is to help people understand that people
want to make mistakes things are gonna
happen that if we don't get these guys a
second chance and we do not get an
opportunity to be productive members of
society to pay taxes to contribute to
their community to help clean up some of
the mess that they have work of public
communities than what is going to happen
these guys are going to revert back to
the patterns that got them into
situations that begin they be there's
all those negative terms that we know
that are related to flowers for being
used Shinji with my certain works out to
be a tremendous challenge one of the
shocking statistics we got from Canada
at every other male at the bank email
that you talk to them candy as you at
the time was looking to do time and the
question is in a lot of cases the
question is not did you go to jail is
when did you have it's hard but it can
be done and
basically my drug testing we do I do
that it success stories of gradually
probably during the wall in front of the
office of the National Comprehensive
sooner for farmers and Scott madness is
is basically a support system and it
goes to confidence and once these
gentlemen go through this code
management and get these characteristics
it's amazing because they go on it
coming one way and they need love
another way kubrick way too drunk for a
year I'm partage in June over Central
Java pointing it management specialist
and basically my job is to go out and
try to talk about us and Kirby Thunder
computer programmers aya and try to seek
employment and also people we deal with
different issues of relationship issues
a lesion in children with their former
wives and they doing with themselves
well sometimes a little disastrous
Muhammad record is giving men new to the
program instruction on an exercise
designed to build camaraderie and trust
and then put on blindfold and have an
escort to leave it alone two sets up
little right this isn't done just in the
office when i'm in the city screech from
third case in walnut to the last session
are you walking on a side day with busy
what's in front of you and you can see
listen backing Oh what I was thinking I
hope I'll know is God has got my babies
in the wrong direction and car plus
anything they didn't I don't know oh my
god
like my downturn or off campus on fight
I got there like the wrong bag so we
should've gone to the right path yeah
like that was me not too long ago so
looking at them looking at the pit trust
in each other that makes me happy
because we did that we made it happen we
made it happen so that they can take a
step further you'd only be able to trust
each other happy little fun this
exercise to their daily walking life I'm
trying for this into my daughter like
artists you know this heavier this
having a different outlook on life and
not knowing that everybody's not out to
get you you know with certain things in
certain places that you have to put your
trust in tune to benefit you know that i
find myself today and i will find us
about dull knife I'll just putting you
know trusted to myself first and then
two other people were maybe I will be
successful at nornand so by sticking
with the program will for a prisoner
honoring the life of his late mother by
turning his own life around for what I'm
about to plate batting president hey
that's just a loser but this program
done for me is not enough time is not
any worth taking the shuttle is
beautiful organization toughening the
same a lot of history function at the
station
table my burgers are struggling this
morning gave up our struggle this past
winter so forth how is short like house
on a robot Monday but some disdain
seeing cycle it somewhere like cookies
she had a beautiful life hundreds of men
put their trust in the program's change
their lives and our forever grateful
once again thank God thank you do you
know someone who could benefit from the
comprehensive center for fathers and so
at the coldest in Iraq to us five seven
one seven four thousand or Cleveland
visions done 6abc.com only that point is
either treatment sign in the dark so I I
do want to address the color things so
just very quickly that got a fool of a
standard so eloquently but proposed a
definitely contributed not in our brain
but in early as it relates to trying to
work with the other energies that we
found ourselves in that have control of
these situations in Philadelphia as you
might have been reading the papers over
the past year there have been at least
seven police officers in it than having
slain each of those police officers were
slain by a person of color and just
recently the officer Kowalski was a shot
and killed in the western flank area in
Philadelphia and the only statement that
was made after that even by the Police
Commission was they didn't shoot the
young man enough and that the we should
Devon go back to LA tomorrow
ki well at the National copy has a
several fathers we took issue with that
because none of the politicians were
saying anything none of the parts
leaders in the community the most seen
anything so we organized a faith walk
and just there a week and a half ago we
have 100 men blindfolded walking from
where the slain officer where the
officer was murdered to the police
district that's full four blocks away
but after center the biggest street and
the center seat speed in Colombian Broad
Street coupled with them were the
leaders of our community we had this
faithful and we have people from the
faith community coming saying prayers it
opened with libation and not cry my wife
my love so dearly open the day with
libation we have representation from the
Catholic Church from the Islamic
community from the Baptist community and
all of these faith leaders said their
prayers we walked on and on with those
hundred men blindfolded with the with
the knowledge that these young men can
definitely come out of the darkness into
the light when we reach the police
department the police office of
themselves were astounded that a whole
morning because we said that we are
there to have faith in you faith in the
city faith in ourselves and faith in God
that we can work together to better make
a difference their faces was shot and
when the crowd came in front of the
police department the police captain
came out we applauded them and they just
couldn't get open but we didn't stop
there we called for a dialogue for
justice for fathers and families which
will be on April 28 have the national
company
actually as I dialogue to to be able to
sit down and talk about what things that
really need to happen to be able to make
a difference and I have to come to an
end out without Allah say one thing
lovely change can happen have the
National Comprehensive several father's
we serve over 200 mil a year that's our
mandate we had to place eighty-five
percent of them we make that number the
average family doesn't get over ten
dollars now and benefits and then we
have to track them to six months in to
interpret their attention my programmer
attention has to be eighty-five percent
right now our program attendance is
ninety-seven percent for the year our
job attention for the end of the year
has to be sixty percent and we're
trapping 60 plows of the men standing
those jobs so it's not that it cannot be
done it can be done and we can go we
have between how to go to the table we
have to go to the table of legislation
we have to be able to convince the
lawmakers to make change such as one
hundred percent pass through when a
prison for patient child support because
of their in Philadelphia only 50,000
don't care how it's your child in rizal
only fifty dollars goes to the child
there needs to be tax credit for those
things that are paying child support and
we need to stop the recruitment of
payments whether individually is knocked
up because it where these you have to go
you did five years you got your pain
when you carve you up your child support
payment is $50,000 waiting with the
money and in the system they have the
way within the judge has the wherewithal
to be able to say look I know you're in
the rear just morning by charging dollar
week they can do that they can do that
they've tried these different things
with cases like Wisconsin then South
Dakota and they work we have to be able
to
particularly our colleges those that are
in the telogen sia arena you have to
write those papers that make sense to
the legislation you have to be the voice
of the community that said change can
happen and change look based on you I
thank you for your time and watching the
film and yes we are the National copy
has a several files in Philadelphia and
the phone number is 215
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu